bouffard bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode des deux probablement
aujourd'hui j'accueille nicolas minier
docteur en biologie dont virgin rubio
l'énergie et l'un des auteurs aussi de
la tribune nov excellent niveau là ça va
bonjour ça va bien on va parler de nos
sections sont que c'est l'actualité tout
ça mais d'avoir ce que je peux te
présenter parler de ton parcours
est ce que tu es aussi ouais alors
personnellement j'ai un parcours qui est
l'universitaire commencé par une passe
est ce une licence en biotechnologie à
lorient puis il monte à paris pour un
master en ingénierie biomédicale et je
me suis spécialisé notamment dans ce
qu'on appelle les biomatériaux c'est à
dire plus ou moins utilisé la matière
pour contrôler on va dire un peu le
vivant est typiquement domaines
d'application de prédilection c'est ce
qu'on appelle les organes cheap c'est à
dire d une sorte de creil des boîtes de
pétri en 2d où on a des seuils de
cultiver des tissus en en 3d pour
reproduire une complicité s'est
tissulaire plus importante et plus
pertinente si on veut faire de la pub
logique soit fondamentale ou alors des
tests précliniques tester des drogues
sur ce genre de d'organes miniature si
on veut et elle a du coup je suis en
première année de thèse du coup la
banque est donc ça fait un an que je
suis à l'institut pasteur a travaillé là
dessus mais j'ai relu le domaine de
recherche il a commencé de l'est je
pense qu'un des papiers qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est un papier de 2006 qui
montre vraiment de manière très très net
l'importance en fait du de la physique
dans le comportement des cellules en
fait c'est un papier qui est je sais
qu'il est brillant qui comme on aime
bien à part pour les démonstrations qui
montre que fois qu'il monte vraiment que
voilà on est passé pendant de longues
années pendant des décennies à côté
d'eux à côté de tout ça et qu'on a
souvent considéré la chimie comme étant
le seul moteur du du vivant en côte hill
entre les cellules sont finale des
grosse équation chimiques mais en fait
ce sont ces dispositions physiques et
donc un papier 2006 qui montrent que
voilà tout ce qu'on avait fait avant
sans prendre en compte la physique
mérite de crosse cros d'amélioration
hockey aux amendements
quand il a vu que c'est quoi comme physx
alors typiquement ça va être la capacité
ce papier ci en particulier de la
capacité des cellules à apercevoir la
rigidité du milieu dans laquelle à son
cercle typiquement et s'il ne va pas se
comporter de la même manière selon que
le substrat sur lequel elles évoluent et
à kribi pas grippé et stif rigide ou
plus souple et en fait cette
information-là à elles seules peuvent
aller jusqu à induire une
différenciation de cellules souches
typiquement un kebabier 2006 dont je
parle c'est un papier qui montrent que
des cellules souches mais anti mal aimés
6 peuvent se différencier c'est lui qui
est issu souche qui sont assez
pluripotentes clairement qu'ils peuvent
se différencier en des tissus qui vont
appartenir à loos son muscle au ono pas
deux neurones revenir à des cellules
neurales où est donc la simple
information du substrat en fait sur
lequel ces cellules sont cultivés en
fête permet de se différencier sur tel
ou tel de s'orienter sur telle ou telle
voie un clé de différenciation sans
qu'on ait à changer les facteurs
environnants alors que pour l'instant
c'était la seule chose quasiment sur
laquelle on misait en fait on disait sur
des facteurs de croissance qui était
spécifique de telle ou telle voie et ont
négligé complètement la physique à quai
et la sas quelque chose qui est quand
même en train de changer
depuis depuis deux décennies on va dire
ok mais la biologie s'enrichit
énormément avec ça et donc notamment ces
raisons je pense que cette manière de
rebondir sur la chaîne que j'ai lancé
sur youtube j'ai lancé quand j'étais au
japon donc il ya deux ans maintenant où
justement j'ai envie de parler de ça de
communité ça le fait que la biologie en
fait et l espèce de de carrefour depuis
la fin du xxème siècle où elle s'est
soudainement enrichi en fait de tout ce
que les autres sciences avait lui
apporté notamment les sciences
informatiques notamment les sciences
physiques et qu'en fait du coup la
sémiologie réellement en train de faire
des progrès monstrueux grâce à des
ajouts d'autres sciences et donc voilà
nous c'est plus ou moins le thème que
j'avais envie d'avoir des dents sur
cette chaîne youtube qui a pas beaucoup
de prétention pour l'instant
tu étais pas vocation à être
professionnalisant que je crois pas que
du coup ça c'est un champ de recherche
je connais absolument pas battu par les
empêche pas des perspectives de cette
recherche
à va pour parler de typiquement le champ
d'application quand je travaille les
organes cheap
donc pour faire très simple il y avait
une conférence que j'espère que je vais
recommander à beaucoup de monde
une conférence ted qui a été donné par
jennifer n'a pas loupé par géraldine
hamilton qui est une scientifique qui
travaille maintenant pour émile eid qui
est en passe de devenir le leader
mondial de ce genre de technologie qui
définissait le trou de manière très
efficace
son job elle disait qu'elle était une
espèce d'architectes pour cellules en
fait circulent sur son job et de de
créer des outils in vitro dont le la
préoccupation en fait les deux fournir à
des cellules à un environnement le plus
agréable le plus familier possible en
fait ça prend comme je disais avant à la
fois la biologie au sens chimique on va
dire la chimie des êtres vivants mais
également la physique je trouvais cette
définition qui était assez assez bien
celui défini ces mêmes communes
architecte pour cellules [ __ ] ils ont
été de construire des maisons dans
lesquelles et les cellules sont les plus
les plus confortable possible est plus à
l'aise se différencie le mieux est donc
les champs d'application j'en parlais
très brièvement avant il ya la biologie
fondamentale où on s'interroge justement
sur qu'est ce qui plaît aux cellules
qu'est ce qui plaît at-elle organes etc
et aussi des champs d'application
beaucoup plus on va dire approche de de
l'industrie ou du de l'applicatif et
notamment des gros espoirs de ces de ces
technologies là des organes en plus des
hormones and cheap c'est des tests
quelques pré clinique c'est-à-dire le
droit ex collègues d'hier de tester des
drogues en anglais des molécules en fait
nous sentir qu'elles soient des toxiques
susceptibles d oxyde suspecté ou alors
des molécules pharmaceutiques potentiel
de les tester sur c'est sur ces objets
sur 7
un chip qui sont plus pertinents que les
boîtes de pétri in toutes les cellules
comme cultivées en 2d jusqu'ici sur des
matériaux très stift et puis quand la
flasque on utilise cdc en pet 100 giga
pascal de rigidité ces trucs très très
rigide avec beaucoup plus que plus que
le vivant qui va plutôt du kilo pascal
centaines de kilos pascal on est
plusieurs blogs en dessous clairement et
donc grâce à ces outils on va dire plus
pertinente que les boîtes de pétri qu'on
espère avoir des tests précliniques des
tests pour des médicaments potentiels
qui sont beaucoup plus pertinentes avant
et notamment suffisamment pertinent pour
que on arrive à se débarrasser ou à
évacuer une partie de nos besoins en
test sur les animaux notamment
donc c'est à la fois quelque chose mais
qui peut rapporter parce que c'est moins
cher que des animaux qui est aussi plus
pertinent et plus représentatifs et de
la physiologie humaine puisque du coup
il va avoir des dessus des cellules
humaines qui sont à réellement dans de
bonnes conditions qu'on se comportait
comme de l'humain et d'accélérer le
processus de libération a besoin d'eux
une opération d'itérations d'une
expérience à l'autre c'est pour ça c'est
entre autres les avantages ça sur
l'animal ou c'est ça la fout les
avantages sur l'animal à leurs frais des
avantages sur l'humain tel qu'on le
pratique aujourd'hui et et c'est plus
pertinents et moins cher donc a priori
c'est un champ de recherche dit pas
quelle création à grandir dans les
années à venir soit hier est ce que
j'imagine qu'en plus il ya encore plein
de voies explorées
oui oui parce que nous avons dit c'est
quelque chose qu'on a découvert il ya
une de défunts pas connaître découvert
mais quand on a réalisé l'importance
qu'on a réalisé qu'on avait sous-estimé
cette importance il ya quelques
décennies à peine way et judas biologie
gosset y avait des lésions que je
prenais pour parler que je parle du
début de la vidéo de présentation de la
chaîne qui était qu' il y avait beaucoup
de scientifiques avaient fini par
décrire le xxème siècle mettant le le
siècle de la physique avec l'exploration
spatiale avec l'informatique
électronique et qu'ils pressentaient ou
qui prophétise et que le 21e serait sans
doute cela
de la biologie entre autres grâce au
fait que l'asie qui est passée par là et
qui est maintenant la physique
l'informatique ont énormément de choses
à apporter de biologie on se dirige vers
man sur des abus sur des avancées dans
le domaine dans le domaine médical qui
devrait assez sympa franchement pour le
21e siècle d'être qu'il y avait quelque
chose juste moi qui une image que je
vais être parfois sur les réseaux
sociaux ou sur le pessimisme ambiant on
se dit que on arrivait trop tard pour
explorer notre monde on arrivait trop
tôt pour explorer l'espace et j'avais le
revenant mais la biologie c'est
maintenant il ya des trucs absolument
monstrueux qu'on va qu'on va découvrir
dont vous en faites pas on va jamais
évident qu'il va y avoir des choses de
l'actualité absolument génial un pc pour
le siècle à venir on va pas rester en
reste
c'est sûr si vous y allez un sujet
d'étude mais je pense que ce pack eu que
la biologie mais en particulier en tout
cas la biologie un sujet d'étude
tellement complexe de vol et est
tellement de nouveaux outils pour
explorer ce monde que forcément plein de
choses à découvrir
là aussi c'est cool toi ton sujet des
tests en particulier
alors mon sujet tech en particulier
c'est de développer une technologie qui
a vocation à être implémentée dans c
dans ses organes cheap ou look sur ses
organes miniature donc plus précisément
je m'intéresse à je suis sous direction
d'un directeur de tech s'appelle sami
goba qui est spécialisé dans les
hydroliennes qui passait par le pfl dans
un labo vraiment spécialisé dans les
hydrocarbures dans le peg le
polyéthylène glycol qui est à une
molécule qu'on va pouvoir gris fait de
manière très facile manière très brève à
dire facile on qui du coup va de pouvoir
de fait devenir vraiment leur tâche va
pouvoir
on va pour la fonctionnalité un peu
comme on veut en faire un peu ce qu'on
veut et avoir des gels aux propriétés
très contrôlés que ce soit mécaniquement
ou chimiquement
donc ce n'est celle très intéressant
donc on va pouvoir cultiver des cellules
à la fois dedans et dessus pour avoir
refroidi reproduire une complexité
tissulaire assez assez important qu'en
fait c'est donc la première application
à laquelle je m'attèle c'est un get one
chip donc un intestin en fait sur plus
aucune barrière intestinale sur laquelle
on va pouvoir tester des molécules sur
laquelle on va pouvoir tester des
conditions voir comment se comporte nord
nos cellules et c'est de reproduire en
attestant le plus fiable possible et
puis ma pasteur oblige la spécialité de
pasteur ça reste comme l'infection
on va balancer des petites bactéries
dessus 1 vous savez comment ça c'est le
défi des applications les plus
pertinentes de ses organes chip sécu
c'est pour utiliser par an pour faire un
peu de biologie sur des pathogènes qui
sont exclusivement humain c'est à dire
que pour l'instant donc mal excellent
exemple de dechy galactrix neri donc une
une bactérie pathogène qui provoque pour
faire ça finci kg s'est fait ressentir
une grosse série qui est exclusivement
ou pbx franks exclusivement humaine
en fait et donc on ne peut pas faire de
test chez l'animal et lorsqu'on faisait
des tests sur nos cellules en 2d alors
on a fait jamais des trucs qui
ressemblait vraiment à ce qu'on observe
à chez des humains sauf que bon on va
pas infecter des humains simplement
parce que parce que pourquoi pas on a
passé j'espère que fait l'occident que
l'humanité a passé ce cap on arrêtait de
faire ça mais du coup pas nos organes et
le chip qui sont d'une complexité
tissulaire biologique plus importante
que nos anciennes votre pétri flasque en
2d va du coup permettre maintenant
d'avoir des résultats beaucoup plus
proche du vivant et donc on est pensée
pour ces pathogènes exclusivement humain
on a vraiment l'espoir de réussir à
apprendre beaucoup de choses dans les
années à venir
cool et donc tu es en première année
sont première des tests mais j'ai
commencé en septembre l'année dernière
ont d'ailleurs à dix mois du bien ça va
pour l'instant puis se passe bien je me
trouve lent après tout ce qu'on fait des
thèses me disent inquiets de voir les
premières années suivantes y trouve le
bon je me dis ok c'est bon courage donc
sur le top ten des incentives chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle brève voile avec
un petit cube derrière c'est sorte de
face et le début de nos rêveries fabio
révolution bio rêverie dieu revue en
fait le fait c'est vraiment exactement
jouxtait le peut-être que j'avais un
autre nom au début une place des
finalement pas et j'aime bien celui-ci
même si le petit qu il fait chier parce
que non le char yves jamait l'expert du
parquet
mattel du reste trois maintenant mais
l'objectif barça c'est bio révolution
parce que c'est ce qu'on est en train de
vivre la biologie vraiment en train de
passer à une vitesse et de passes
étaient supérieurs bio rêverie parce que
c'est ce que nous permet en fait cette
révolution comme on ne sait pas encore
ça va nous mener typiquement un exemple
sa tête christophe caze nine qui a des
qui rend extrêmement facile des
organismes génétiquement modifiés
extrêmement contrôlée est qui et qui du
coup à des applications qu'on soupçonne
pas encore et qui va vraiment prendre
beaucoup de place donc ça c'est sûr aux
rêveries parce que on est autorisé à ses
rêveries grâce à la bo révolution et du
revu parce que c'est ce que j'ai envie
de faire de cette chaîne c'est à dire
une revue de l'actualité dans ce sens
une revue de nos connaissances etc
la vulgarisation au sens large choix
très chouette et donc peut passer un
petit peu aof exxon
du coup fait partie des auteurs de cette
tribune que joconde aux 8 heures de les
voir si on peu entendu parler
donc c'est une feuille point sereine ce
mois là est ce que tu peux nous raconter
comment quand tu te retrouvais dans ce
truc de science comment je me suis
retrouvé là dedans
lance ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
fait en ce moment une je sais pas si je
vais appeler sa nouvelle génération mais
un renouveau des pratiques dans la
recherche qui sans doute amené aussi
qu'une nouvelle génération de chercheurs
ou simplement de passionnés des sciences
également qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
proche du public qui investissent les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit pour parler
de leur domaine vulgariser et parfois
aussi pour réagir à l'actualité
et donc on s intéresse de nouvelles
vagues de chercheurs et de passionnés
qui sont compétents et accessible en
fait au public et je pense que c'est le
premier point et il se trouve qu'il ya
une espèce de caen appeler ça une
quelque chose de chouette un petit peu
là tant de frustrations de pas mal de
chercheurs de voir que leurs travaux
sont parfois simplifié simplement ou que
parfois même couleur sur la base d'un
article était pourtant bon d'avoir des
gens qui des gens qui vont utiliser ou
se prétendre de la science se prétendent
leurs résultats pour justifier des pour
justifier des points de vue des prises
de positions qui sont importants parce
que c'est le justiciable parce que parce
que le sur des sites et des produits
jusque là donc l espèce de frustration
et de des coûts de génération de
scientifiques lac ciblées qui est
accessible par non et qui réagissent à
l'actualité et et voilà il ya eu
plusieurs reportages en tout début
d'année qui avaient étaient des sortes
de goutte de trop écoute d'eau qui avait
fait déborder le vase
et voilà donc un petit peu sur le repas
se monter un petit peu sur l'exemple qui
avait donné les 124 médecins à l'année
dernière on s'est dit bah merde
peut-être que des fois poussé une
gueulante ça marche et course et ouais
mais nous aussi on fait tous des
violentes a poussé tombe à allonger et
donc ça avait commencé sur sur twitter
avec des tweets de gens qui proposait
simplement de devenir cause regrouper
qu'on écrive un truc et donc on s'est
retrouvé sur un serveur discorde à
pension je pense qu'on peut dire une
petite centaine de personnes sur un
serveur descordes à échanger on a ouvert
un bouledogue on a écrit ça va être
plein de boulet de poynt tout ce qui
pour nous aller pas super bien et qu'ils
font est améliorée je crois que c'est
différent
une page une page et demie de boulettes
punt dans tous les sens et puis on s'est
dit on a laissé ouvert le google docs
qu'on a dit voilà tout le monde on
modifier ce truc là on lui donne une
forme on lui donne un plan et puis on en
fait une tribune dont on est à peu près
content
et alors que cette tribune ce premier
jeu la tribune froid qui faisait si je
dis pas de bêtises 13 ou 15 pages où on
était relativement exhaustif mais on
arrivait à aborder suffisamment de
points pour pas être mal an pour pas
laisser de malentendu on arrivait à être
suffisamment précises en ce qu'on
voulait sur qu'est ce qu'on voulait
critiqué ce qu'est ce qu'on voulait pas
critiquer ce genre de choses et une fois
qu'on avait cette tribune de 13 15 pages
on s'est rapproché de médias et on leur
a demandé voilà si jamais on avait envie
d'être publié chez vous qu est ce qu on
a quoi casser les règles du jeu en fait
puisque c'est bien que nous on a ce
qu'on a envie de dire et puis à ce que
les médias et directe du jeu des médias
qu'est-ce qu'on peut se permettre de
publier et pour tout le monde je crois
qu'on est de réponse vraiment différent
pour tout le monde c'est un gabarit
autour de 800 mo ce qui fait à peu près
5000 caractère et pour tout le monde
c'était ça c'était voilà si ça rentre la
danse
on se posera la question de ce qu'on
publie ou pas et tant que ça rentre pas
là-dedans bah c'est pas la peine n'est
plus tard et donc du coup ben alors les
choix qu'on a ce moment là on était à
février peut-être fin février à soual
avoueront détourner du coup on travaille
plus on s'est dit bon ok on a chacun on
s'est dit que chacun allait proposer une
version synthétique de ses quinze pages
qu'on avait écrite et voilà donc ensuite
chacun propose son truc et puis on vote
pour celui qui a fait partie dans la
meilleure direction ce qui semblait
tamisant direction et puis ces trucs là
bas on la retravaille à plusieurs et
puis on relève l'auteur pour sûr de
continuité dans l'écriture on a flotté
leur apporter les modifications que les
autres ont souhaité apporter etc et donc
on va là on essaie de des grossistes à
petit à petit et attise donc ça ça a été
attirée ça veut dire enrichissant une
porte très frustrant puisque du coup nos
quinze pages se retrouve dans une demi
page un petit peu plus qu une demi page
a pas forcément tout ce qu'on veut dire
n'y ait pas ce qu'on voulait dire ce
qu'on estimait devait être sujet à
pincettes pas du coup il n'y a pas la
place pour les pincettes en plus du
message faut que ça rentre ses deux
lancers
c'est le jeu quoi ces arrivants soir on
publie ce truc là qui est le mieux qu'on
a depuis dû adapter notre tribu de 15
pages ou alors on publie rien et à un
moment il ya des choix à faire
s'il faut publier bon il ya des
concessions qui vont devoir être faites
et qui ont maintenant été fait et après
forcément les choix peuvent être le show
peuvent être questionnés mais tout ce
qu'on a fait on a une raison de trouver
toutes les formes tous les points
abordés enfin tous les points qu'on a pu
lui reprocher c'est des points qu'on
avait abordé on sait pourquoi on l'a
fait on est parfois même souvent
d'accord pour dire que c'est pas parfait
mais bath comme on dit c'est ça ou c'est
pas publier quoi donc un moment à cet
appareil de nos facs med
j'en vois juste en podcast précédente
malgré que j'avais fait avec jérémy
d'escroquer des créateurs de trivino
sinopec med et donc si j'ai bien compris
lukla la jeunesse du strict n'est pas
dans un docu de reportage ça franchement
de penser à celui de dans les spéciales
seront tôt ou ouais je pense qu'il y
avait eu un autre avant je vous lier
mais après ça dépense des coutumes et
nos plans chacun voit comme celle de
bio-ingénierie les assauts de
technologie effectivement les bateaux
gmg sur un peu plus sensible que ce qui
va concerner nucléaire ou et ça concerne
nucléaire je suis plutôt à demander des
conseils à des gens qui donc pour moi
oui
l'envoyé spécial du fiat a été je pense
pour tout la team bio on va dire qui
s'annonce pour tous de la partie bio non
respect ça lui pose att assez assez
corsé ans et donc donc ça c'était il ya
six mois c'est janvier aujourd'hui
s'arrangeront ça c'est toujours que ce
reportage était en janvier que vous avez
commencé très tôt début février
d'accord assez rapidement après
et ça c'est moi aussi cette histoire de
pardonner d'avoir les quinze pages de la
signalétique vous est ce que conclut m
alors les quinze pages les quinze pages
est ce qu'on la sauvegarde et peut-être
qu'on a ça serait pas mal que je ne sais
pas si on les a en fait puisque ça se
trouve on a des gros si ces quinze pages
et du coup supprimer six mêmes dossiers
c'est à dire qu'on a des grossistes et
15 pages
si on dit qu'on les a fait fondre j'ai
un peu peur qu est-ce que ce qui est soi
pas c'est parce que c'est pas que ça
peut être intéressant d'avoir une
tribune beaucoup plus longue
publié en ligne par exemple faut que
situation peut on un drap si on a si on
à la tribune le plus complète et juste
mettre sur le site
ça peut être une ressource intéressante
oui les gens en afrique souhaite
compléter aussi parce qu'on sait que il
ya une réflexion qu'ont ces prises
plusieurs fois c'est de ne pas avoir
assez de gens qui viennent des sciences
humaines et sociales ou des sciences
molles entre guillemets il ya peut-être
de truc qui fait il ya un truc qui fut
double peine c'est qu'en fait nous
reproche aussi d'avoir mis d'exemples de
shs et c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu en
mettre
mais en même temps ce que 15,7 ce qu'il
faut clarifier aussi c'est que on n'a
pas fait beaucoup de gens des sachets je
crois que dans les 250 premiers
signataires maintenant on a on a
plusieurs personnes qui viennent de
philosophie le sociologue c'est vrai que
peut-être pas maintenant on a été
rejoint par des sociologues depuis que
la tribune est publiée je crois qu'il
est juste il ya quelques heures on a
craint que virgin tournai qu'il met d
une sociologue médaillé d'argent je
crois cnrs qui nous a rejoint turin pour
son soutien mais c'est vrai que les
initiaux on n'a pas énormément et ça
tient pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
du fait d'un désintéressement en fait
c'est simplement une question de de
carnet d adresses en fait des gens qui
vient d'en et je sais pas si j'arriverai
à cons j'espère que le changement est
prêt à combattre mais on peut prendre
dix ans puis a même dans les sciences
dures aussi à des domaines qui sont pas
représentés en fait défection des
géologues où on en a pas dans les 250
premiers des astrophysiciens on n'a pas
non plus et donc vraiment c'est pas
certes il ya des mayas les domaines des
shs qui sont ils sont pas représentés
mais il ya aussi des domaines des
sciences dures qui sont pas représentés
c'est vraiment une question des carnets
d'adressés des gens qui se sont
mobilisés à la première heure c'est pas
du tout du tout une question de choix ou
de lignes taurian est en fait la double
peine dont je parlais c'est que comme
justement on n'avait pas énormément de
gens par exemple de géologie ou d'astro
d'astrophysique
on n'a pas pris des exemples
d'astrophysique dans la tribune parce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu parler au nom de
deux domaines de compétences ne sont pas
les nôtres
et pareil du coup on n'a pas de
l'exemple de sachets sont peut-être
qu'on aurait pu trouver quelque chose
sur sur les écarts de salaires
hommes-femmes je pense qu'on va
peut-être plus permettre sur un truc
comme ça de se permettre de penser qu'il
ya un consensus qu'il ya il ya vraiment
un truc suffisamment solides pour
qu'eux-mêmes n'ont pu se permettre de le
dire mais on aurait pu trouver un
exemple et on s'est pas senti la
légitimité de le faire sans que dans les
dents les initiateurs il ya quelqu'un
des sachets ce qu'on lui dira ok ça vous
pouvez l'écrire de ma confiance
cette phrase là elle est solide elle
sera pas reprocher et sa chasse ne
viendra pas ne viendront pas vous le
reprocher non ça c'est vraiment une
question de carnets d'un reste plus que
deux choix en fait puisque des choix
éditoriaux on n'a pas fait beaucoup
c'est pas facile de laisser vos
priorités compétence n'a pas n'a pas
accès aux puisque forcément là qu'on
aimerait sa chaise on va sans doute
perdre on connaît plein de gens
compétents ou des gens qui serait
intéressé par ça mais nous on en rit
sachets c'est donc dans mon carnet dares
j'ai pas beaucoup de gens à d'autres je
voulais tribunal n'a pas voulu on peut
pas se permettre de la rendre publique
avant publication du coup effectivement
on peut pas faire un grand col sur
twitter en emballant sur la tribune à
tout le monde et en demandant à tout le
monde de venir jeter un oeil parce que
sinon elle est de fait publier s'adapter
au grand intérêt pour un média d'avoir
la primauté des trucs quoi passer des
équations comme ça on a essayé de gagner
parce que c'est ce qu'un truc qui
appelle un peu tout essayé que tous les
scientifiques font qui essaie d'appeler
tous les scientifiques et certains
peuvent pas se sentir représentés par
ces tribunes
dans des statisticiens aussi dans tout
le district mais combien la ccsa combien
manade statisticiens 2,3 peut-être et
puis c'est tout c'est vrai qu'il ya des
domaines qui du coup sont plus de santé
d'autres je pense que là typiquement la
biologie et d'écologie végétale avec
l'agronomie le la team des ingénieurs
nucléaires
ces trucs qui sont sur représentés par
rapport au reste
et encore une fois c'est pas une
question de ligne éditoriale citation de
charles adresse quoi il faut voir les
france les vous avez parce que dans la
tribune du coup mis en avant si
consensus scientifique dans trois
domaines différents
et en ce que pour voir ça comme des
exemples de choses à pomport et je
précise c'est comme ça que vous percevez
c'est des exemples parmi d'autres ou
être que sont les exemples principaux en
fait le choix d exemple ce qu'il fallait
absolument c'est une question est ce que
vous faites un truc est peut-être pas
été compris par tous ou peut-être qu'on
a mal expliqué ce à peu près pas qu'ils
vivent dans les faits n'a pas été
finalement compris comme nous on aurait
souhaité que ce soit complet
ces exemples ci n'ont absolument pas
vocation à convaincre les gens cercle on
sait très bien qu'une phrase un sujet
verbe complément suivie d'une séance
suivie d'une référence à un texte qui
est institutionnel plus que parce qu'à
des milk
on sait très bien que ça n'a pas
vocation à convaincre les gens qu'on
veut pas que quand quelqu'un lit notre
phrase sur le co2 nucléaire du coup il
change d'avis bernie effectivement
nucléaire ça ça rejette moins de co2 que
pas mal d'autres choses mais par contre
ce qu'il fallait c'est un truc qui soit
on va dire solide et peut-être le mot
consensus
on reviendra de suie une affirmation
solide dont la politique est plus ou
moins sûr à et qui est mal traitée assez
souvent par ou bien
part directement par un média parce que
soient journalistes et partisans soient
journalistes manquent un peu de
formations dans semaine là mais sont
nécessairement que de mauvaises
intentions ou soit parce que le
traitement est un tout petit peu on va
dire cadrés sur le cadrage fait
simplement que les débats citoyens qui
découle derrière en fait sont eux
convaincus de se baser sur quelque chose
de très rationnel alors que pas d'intro
donc il fallait absolument une
information correcte autant que possible
qui est un petit peu malmené soit par
les médias soit par le débat public qui
en découlent derrière ces affirmations
ne sont absolument pas vocation à être
exhaustive en fait et parfois et même
assez souvent
l'affirmation ne regroupe qu'une toute
petite partie du débat qui peut y avoir
sur sur un domaine
typiquement le nucléaire c'est
absolument pas le choix des mix
énergétique n'est absolument pas une
question qui se résume à la quantité de
co2 émise par mégawattheure et donc donc
c'est nécessairement non exhaustif il
fallait une phrase voilà courte et une
affirmation en laquelle on peut avoir
confiance
non c'est pas vrai si je vais revenir un
peu à la génèse électrique donc qui les
élit chacun et une centaine lors sur le
discorde c'est de la bêtise je trouve je
crois qu on est un petit peu moins d'une
centaine tête autour de 80 90 avec un
choeur qui était très actif un coeur
d'une tête une vingtaine trentaine de
personnes dès février et dont l'on va
dire une vingtaine de personnes qui ont
été relativement régulier qui ont de
gros apport depuis février et jusque
maintenant en juillet si je me trompe
avec 20 donc on sait on a déclaré 20
rédacteurs ok c'est un vin personnes qui
s'y engagent un petit peu leur leurs
paroles lorsqu'il prit dans la tribune
et les 250 autres qui apporte un soutien
et qu'y a t'il reprochera pas d'être un
petit peu plus petit format mais nous on
n'est pas personne je n'ai aucune
tribune qui avait été écrite par
par par les vins un rédacteur qui était
la présérie d'absolument tout le monde
et ils tombaient comme une évidence
puisque ya eu plein de choix à faire
rester d'épellation à peu compliquée à
résoudre en termes de l'efficacité de ce
qui est dit de justesse que si vite et
tenter
du coup l'occasion justement ces
histoires de comment vous avez fait pour
choisir une première version en tout cas
qu'ils avaient plusieurs propositions
au début on a fait un truc qui était
très collégial où chacun écrivait un
petit peu sur sa partie donc il ya des
gens qui étaient plus spécialisés des
médias et interactions science médias
est qui et qui écrivait beaucoup les
parties d'introduction et de conclusion
sur sur la place de la science sur la
place des médias ce genre de choses et
ensuite les différentes équipes si on va
plus à des équipements vers les groupes
spécialisés par leurs études dans la
biologie dans le nucléaire dans ceci
pour cela est au fait leur parti avec
des phrases dont il était confiant et
satisfait et sur lequel il était
vraiment un problème dans dans le débat
public est potentiellement du fait de
parfois mais rarement de scientifiques
ni les temps de parole de journalisme
militant assez souvent simplement d'un
billet de cadrage inde est beaucoup plus
systémique que la mauvaise intention de
demain tel ou un tel nom et du coup il
est combien de versions proposées si je
dis pas de bêtises on devait avoir huit
versions différentes de 8,8 g 8
directions différentes dans l'année elle
on avait tenté de partir et de décider
de choisir finalement cette direction si
et puis ensuite val été à nouveau amendé
par tous ceux qui avaient propos de
choses ces effets un scrutin pour 8
je me rappelle qu est ce qu on a fait je
crois qu'il faut que je l'espère des
gens n'étaient pas mal fans
on a depuis porté des converser on avait
planté des deux
et en fonction de qui était sur le
discours de fond et de quelle église il
prêchait c'est intéressant ce que j'ai
basse à une tâche atteint sentent que de
voir ici à décrire un texte qu aura
plusieurs personnes et d'un collecteur
villes immenses ont été très
intéressants les faits pour nous exercer
là c'est très intéressant pour eux c'est
aussi un retour d'expérience intéressant
pour je pose pas pour ceux qui arrivent
par traille pour ceux qui veulent écrire
des tribunes par la suite très
franchement hésitez pas notre seule
volonté nous c'est le débat donc si vous
pensez que vous avez quelque chose un
jour écrire à peu près sûr c'est sur ces
domaines là n'hésitez pas à venir nous
voir on vous expliquera ce qu'on a fait
ce qui ce qu'on pense avoir vraiment
réussi ce surpoids et on aura peut-être
tendance à vous dire attention là ya un
piège qu'il faut pas tomber sur des
choses vraiment s'il ya des gens qui
veulent des retours d'expérience venez
on est on est super on n'a pas du goût
de la première averse sur la première
version vous pour les jets qui a été
acceptée a été acceptée après ce qu'il y
avait à tous repasser dessus sur sa voie
là une fois qu'on a une fois qu'on a
choisi la direction à prendre
on a tous réadapter ce petit truc là
parce que forcément s'ils savaient si le
les tribunes qui ont été les
orientations prises qui ont été prises
par la biologiste
forcément ça aurait pu être écrite sur
nucléaire peut-être aura pas trop plu à
lahti nucléaire qui va se permettre de
ré agencer un petit truc de remettre une
phrase sans un contexte où alors des
fois comme on a fait cette direction ces
premiers jets on va dire tous
indépendamment les uns des autres
des fois on se rend compte qu'il ya
telle tribune vingtaine est pas super
mais en vrai dans l'introduction il a
été un truc il a une peau ne pas avoir
été du punch line il a une phrase qui me
croisent accroche qui est vraiment sympa
et on va la rapatrier dans si on prend
le même si on prend la direction suivie
par quelqu'un d'autre on s'est cette
fois ci on va la prendre parce que
pendant lé bien donc on enrichit on
prend choisi une direction qui on
enrichit cette direction par tout ce qui
était proposé par un par les autres il
est mis plein temps et craint arriver
une version à arriver une version qui
est proche de celle qui est actuellement
en ligne
ça a dû nous prendre quand même
un mois deux mois facile donc est facile
11 février
ouais mars avril peut-être à la louche
je parlais date en tête mais à la louche
je pense qu'on arrive pas s'ils en avril
où je pense avril comment savoir quelque
chose qui ressemble à ce qui est
aujourd'hui il ya eu ensuite quelques
autres modifications
une fois qu'on a proposé la signature de
des 250 premiers qu'on allait aller
démarcher dans nos carnets deux reste c
est donc s'il ya une remarque il ya une
phrase qui plaisait pas trop à vokoun on
débat on était encore on est encore de
preuves modifications à terme et options
ne faisais moi parce que c'est eux qu'on
a fait signer des gens dont on peut pas
ensuite de revenir vers eux derrière
direct est en fait celui là on va
modifier que ce n'est toujours pas bon
c'est pas permis de faire ça trop
souvent mais on l'a fait ou de foie il
ya deux ans encore des réflexions qui
ont été prises en compte avec les 250
premiers signataires
du coup après donc les fils et un père
sévère sont quasiment final on aimerait
qu'ils aient fait ensuite
ensuite on a il a fallu commencer à
démarcher des journaux alors dans la
mesure en fait où on était un groupe
assez assez hétéroclite on a on avait
des gens chez nous qui aimait référé
thèmes tels journaux puis des gens qui
ne plaît pas ce journal que votre émet
donc il ya eu vraiment il ya de tout et
de conseillers et en plus il y avait
tous les signataires derrière pour
lesquels du coup on pouvait pas se
permettre de faire des choix éditoriaux
à leur place en fait on pouvait
simplement pas se permettre de dire okc
d'assigner et puis maintenant on va
donner connotation politique à ce que ce
que vous avez signé
du coup ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
pris la liste des principaux journaux
français tout la presse quotidienne dans
laquelle il pourrait franchir pertinent
que d'avoir une tribune
de plus la plupart des cours d'eau coup
et on les a tous alignés dans l'ordre de
leur audience et on a commencé par celui
qui a le plus d'audience les pions
descendez petit à petit comme ça
le but du jeu c'était d'avoir une sorte
de méthode au qui fait qu'on n'a pas de
ne met pas de filtre idéologique dans où
il dit au rial pardon dans le choix de
nous on sera publié et on le fait
uniquement sur la tripe sur le critère
du coin de personnes on va toucher
alors après je crois qu'il ya 10 dire
qu'on n'a pas fait de filtres ça se paie
faux puisque nécessairement on s'est
limité à ceux dans lesquels ils
paraissaient partisans de publier très
vite mans sedan dans le pardon dans le
dans le tableau des la presse nationale
à gros tirages et à l'équipe qui se
passe c'est hermine penser que l'équipe
ce qui se passe n'est pas là la place
corps et ses tribunaux donc on n'a fait
que le minimum de filtres éditoriale ont
certes tenu quasi exclusivement à
l'audience en fait qui avait avait le
journal et on les a faits dans l'ordre
et puis non aucun journal était le
préféré d'absolument tout le monde on
savait qu encore une fois c'est un
compromis et puis que et que battre
c'est le nom de l'audience c'est aussi
un truc un peu stratégique quoi parce
que si on publie dans un truc à la
tirage à 10000 vont pas rester coller
les protégés de création d alors le truc
concédé 10 et que en fait on veut pas
valence et ceux qui nous ont retiré
parce que notre message n'est absolument
pas de faire une liste des anti science
on veut pas se retrouver dans une
situation dans une situation pardon où
on publiera une liste de journaux qui
auront refusé une tribune pour qu'on
considère nous comme proscience on veut
surtout pas se mettre enfin un groupe
qui publie une liste de ce à quoi
mais ce que ce que j'avais dit à un
journaliste c'est que grosso modo la
plupart des gros titres auxquels vous
pouvez penser qu'on les a contactés et
ça finit par un reçu et après il est sûr
qu'ils sont extrêmement variés en fait
puisque sûrs il ya des journaux avec qui
on a eu des contacts avec des
journalistes
excellent des journalistes qu'il voulait
qu'ils voulaient oublier et qui en fait
n'ont pas réussi à négocier la rédaction
parce que la réduction était un petit
peu frileuse je ne voulais pas s'avancer
sur un tel ou tel sujet et des fois
c'est au niveau de la rédaction que ça
bloquait des fois c'était des le
journaliste de canal orange en excuser
tout de suite non pas le pen c'est votre
chemin donc il ya vraiment eu
d'hésitation que des fois il ya eu des
fins de non recevoir ou des excuses à un
petit peu un petit peu bidon désolé on
publie plein de choses en ce moment il
ya plusieurs tribunes apparaître puis on
se rend compte qu'en fait nous des
tribunes stern un psychanalyste
donc c'est pas vous voyez milliers
vraiment où il ya des journalistes qui
m'était très je peux dire ami mais avec
des très bons contacts mais il est très
bon retour et puis d'autres où des le
journaliste ça bloque donc tuer tous
vraiment il donc voir ou revoir son
poney situation on met une liste de deux
quotidiens dont on dirait du mal parce
qu'il tout ils sont personne n'est pas
de journaux comparaient départ mais du
coup un peu toutes plus sorte de
réaction de la part des journalistes
mais on doit ou et en dehors après ou
avant même avant on n'a pas eu
énormément de refus motivé avant le fin
avant les la publication ou alors des
fusions très légère en disant je trouve
que c'est pas assez que ce n'est pas
exhaustif on met ça en s'arrêtant là
quoi sont ils n'y a pas eu de on a eu on
a eu des refus motivé pour l'éclosion
inclusive donc qui était aussi un gros
sujet choix la friture inclusive dans
une foire les réactions qui a vu à la
tribune je pas cette envie de coursac
rien du minader mais je récite envie
d'en parler sur le rôle qu'elle peut on
parler c'est vrai que c'est un des
sujets les plus touchées de la tribune
en fait ce qui ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on avait tous une réflexion sur une
des frustrations qu'on avait on va
commencer par là c'est qu'on n'est pas
énormément de femmes dans les
signataires je crois qu'on est à on
peine à atteindre le 20 % ou on n'y est
pas je crois de signataires femmes
ça restera puisque sur ma chaîne oui oui
alors à voter les comparer aussi à
retrouver sur une comparaison quoi il ya
mais on doit on aurait apprécié plus
haut on a essayé de marcher plus de
femmes et vous pouvez y avait ce sujet
entre nous en tout cas
parmi les rédacteurs et sur le discorde
et on s'était demandé ce qu'on
ce qu'on pouvait faire ou pas qu'il y
avait des gens qui étaient il y avait
plusieurs parties qui étaient vraiment
pro écriture inclusive dans le discorde
est en tout cas il ya des personnes qui
étaient allergiques à ça donc il y avait
des gens qui étaient vraiment pour des
gens qui que ça je n'ai pas moi c'est
mon cas je suis pas je suis plus je
préfère les accusés point médian mais
d'avoir toujours réfléchir toujours à
l'écrit à ce que à ne pas avoir de
billet des représentations des genres
mais au final voilà où il y avait des
gens pour des gens qui étaient ni pour
ni contre il y avait juste personnes
allergiques et donc au final on
finalement les clients en écriture
inclusive et puis on a regardé les
réactions des gens et puis en fait que
le premier nous avoir proposé un vrai
refus là dessus on a eu un chercheur
devrait perdre encore une fois ce n'est
pas bon il y en a bien cherché à qui
nous a dit que c'était une ronde que
c'était absolument inadmissible de
malnutrition inclusive et lorsqu'on a
lorsqu'on lui a demandé qui était ce
type ce qu'on n'avait pas constaté me
directement certains collègues que
passer ça et a trouvé qu'en fait c'était
un vieux chercheurs un vieux dinosaures
qui a été connu pour des prises de
positions extrêmement sexy s'extrait
moins misogynes a par le passé est
complètement les différences de
traitement des hommes et des femmes que
ce soit dans la recherche ou ailleurs et
du coup en fait d'avoir eu ce refus d'un
gros misogyne notoire en fait on s'est
dit écriture inclusive ce n'est pas plus
mal si ça peut nous éviter de greffe bah
oui ça c'est le saas et le problème et
puis on a eu peut-être la naïveté de
penser qu'il va rapidement lui n'était
pas serait recentré sur sur le fond au
final bombard ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
rapidement mais passer les passes et les
48 ou 72 premières heures
les gens ont commencé à se calmer sur
les toitures inclusive de l'avoir mis
simple non je regrette pas non il ya pas
un enjeu on sait pourquoi on l'a mis il
ya eu des moments où peut-être que
c'était en off et que les gens sont pas
rendus compte que le coup ça nous avait
plus de de pouvoir se distancier de 2 ou
3 go réac qui aurait pu être plus fait
mal à notre image qu'autre chose donc
non on sait pourquoi on l'a fait
et on sait pas s'il y aurait eu un
meilleur
est-ce que rue un temps que sa meilleur
accueil
parce qu'en fait avoir un meilleur
accueil de la part de ceux qui nous
critiquent uniquement pour l'écriture
inclusive au final s'est passé pas le
débat qu'on avait envie de lancer
donc ça nous touche moyennement si ça si
ça aurait permis un meilleur accueil
clairement de la part d'autres
disciplines scientifiques
peut-être que on aurait pu avoir un
petit regret ou quelque chose mais on
n'a pas eu ce sentiment
ou alors j'ai pas discuter avec les
personnes qui ont fait part de da sur de
gaulle ayant souhaité que d'autres mais
non c'est pourquoi on l'a fait on n'est
pas on n'est pas déçu de l'avoir fait je
sais pas si c'était à refaire je ne sais
pas sur leurs frais ou pas on en
rediscutera encore une fois est-ce qu'il
ya des choses que tu ferais discret dis
clairement que je ferais différemment
peut-être quelque chose que je ferais
différemment mais ce serait uniquement
parce que j'ai l'expérience de ce truc
ne sais pas je pense pas qu'on ait fait
d'erreurs en fait si je vais sûrement
aussi je me repassais s'ils voyagent en
tant que vous retournez où j'étais mal
dans les mêmes conditions je pense que
j'aurais fait la même chose ou dessus
c'est ça avec moi du passé c'était sur
le quotidien des jeunes à ces questions
là bas je pense que le débat sur
sur les la sous-représentation des shs
qui a été plus mal vécue que la sous
représentation des mathématiciens ou des
astrophysiciens sans doute que ça on n'y
prêterait une oreille plus attentive
avant la tribune et peut-être qu'on
forcerait le forcerait la collaboration
avec des gens qui ne sont pas du tout
dans nos cadres est ce qu'on connaît pas
du tout et on aurai je sais pas en fait
il faudrait même qu'on connaisse et non
parce que sinon ce même si on l'avait
fait en fait on aurait pris on aurait
pris des jantes est un petit peu au
hasard lors fois eu si on aurait pu
peut-être écumé youtube et trouver un
vulgarisateur qui de soude sociaux qui
auraient qui aurait ouvert de 3 2 3
carnet d adresses peut-être qu'on aurait
pu forcer vraiment la marché mais non
vraiment sur le sur le court n'avait pas
on avait vraiment mal identifié puisque
l'on savait qu'elle et les sciences
dures aussi qui n'étaient pas
représentés et puis avait un qui avait
revienne et que ce biais c'est juste le
biais de ce qu'ils publiaient quoi
c'était pas c'était pas n'était pas en
service d'une vision de la science quoi
la mode science à nous c'est pas se
limite pas la biologie et ingénierie
nucléaire ça pour nous c'était très
clair et on n'avait pas le sentiment que
ça transparaît donc peut-être que s'il y
avait un truc a changé on aurait forcé
le on aurait été chercher des gens on
découvrait des gens qu'on ne connaissait
pas personnellement on aurait peut-être
pu faire un truc mais je pense que
fondamentalement ouais on a les choix
qu'on a fait on ils ont zappé tous une
raison d'avoir été d'avoir été pris quoi
peut-être que celui ci c'est le titre le
moins justifiées qui est simplement une
circonstance en fait d'un état de fait
du fait de carnet d adresses peut-être
que celui ci on aurait pu se passer quoi
hésiter à appeler les points de
désaccord entre eux entre nous les
points d awa sarr notamment tous les
goûts quand je t'ai dit les choix des
versions tribune ils ont été faits des
points d'accord c'était longtemps c'est
en avril devant avait là il ya eu
peut-être le constat tout le monde le
partage les points de désaccord
peut-être qu'au début ils ont été sur
à quel point on rentre dans le lard à
quel point on est entre guillemets
gentil ou du coup là entre les deux ce
serait au pédagogue
c'est à dire du mal à expliquer
suffisamment pourquoi est ce qu'on a un
reproche à faire pour que ce soit clair
dans la tête de tout le monde
donc voilà peut-être que peut-être que
ça c'est une des différences qui avec au
final le constat tout le monde l'avait
en fait il ya toujours de la veille dans
sa propre discipline et on avait
suffisamment confiance dans les
compétences de ceux qui l'entouraient
pour qu' il s' ils me disent que ce
conseil le partageant leurs disciplines
respectives
que ce soit vrai également donc le
constat au final on est tous vraiment
d'accord là dessus
peut-être que les différences aurait pu
être dans degré pédagogiques ou mais
qu'on met dans la tribune et moi est le
degré de vindicte encore une fois lancé
notre coup une autre équation de cette
tribune des équations à résoudre sur à
quel point est-ce qu'on veut un une
réaction en fait immédiate ou est ce
qu'on veut préparer le terrain pour pour
la suite est-ce qu'on veut créer le
terrain quelque chose qui se passe
ensuite où est-ce qu'on veut pousser une
gueulante qui fasse réagir immédiatement
qui appelle à une réponse vous à des
prises de position de la part des autres
donc quelqu'un autorités épouse études
passées comment ils ont maintenant c'est
là bas moi il ya un truc que je fais
depuis depuis peut-être un an et je
pense que le hashtag doit être mieux est
pas pour rien qu'ils aient que est aussi
depuis que j'ai vu un bon bouquin c'est
qu'en fait j'essaie toujours aujourd'hui
de considérer et maintenant je suis plus
ou moins convaincus qu'il faut presque à
bord d'un débat en se disant que tout
adversaire
il a raison et au minimum le ciné raison
que sur une chose minimum une à raison
que sur le fait d'avoir raison enfin de
penser ce qu'ils porteront au minimum la
personne en face de toi elle a toujours
raison de penser ce qu elle pense parce
que 97% des humains dans les mêmes
conditions
il aurait fini par tirer une conclusion
est la raison pour c'est ce qu'elle
pense parce que l a vu ceci est la vue
cela etc
c'est ça qui a fait son son background
intellectuelle et donc du coup là
son positionnement c'est la conclusion
de ce à quoi elles étaient exposées
donc elle a raison parce que je pense
qu'on peut faire confiance à
l'intelligence des gens n'y a pas de je
ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent qu'il ya
des gros idiot il comprend rien ils ont
tiré une conclusion il peut faire
confiance en fait que ces conclusions il
en sortirait avec des arguments assez
logique lorsqu'on tourne à peu près
d'accord pour dire que un plus un font
d'eux parlait les équations logique de
base à droite le monde d'accord là
dessus donc en vrai si cette personne
pour ça et de fortes raisons de parier
qu'elle a raison de penser sa
condamnation de ce à quoi était
confronté et donc sur le pense que c'est
j'espère que j'arriverai à faire de ça
on va dire non on approche par la suite
dans les débats et que c'est ce que j'ai
essayé d'insuffler chacun a su fait son
truc à moi ce que j'aurais essayé
d'insuffler c'est ça c'est ok vous avez
raison de penser ce que vous pensez mais
du coup on va pas on va pas débattre la
conclusion je vais me reposer ma
conclusion la vôtre on va reprendre les
arguments au début et on va reprendre le
pourquoi vous pensez ce que vous pensez
c'est son important de réfléchir que
chacun d'entre eux n'ont infléchi c'est
pourquoi est ce que au moment de ses
compétences et donc moi est ce que je
pense et qui pense et ça change c'est
qu'on est plusieurs dans dans ce cas-là
d'en avoir poussé dans cette direction
et à avoir voulu d'abord se mettre
d'accord sur les faits et ensuite on
apprend on aura tous à peu près la même
logique et on arrivera à se mettre
d'accord ensemble mais pour ça faut
qu'on soit d'accord d'abord d'accord sur
les fermes
je crois qu'il faut être en revenir aux
faits plutôt que d'opposer des
conclusions ce que vous et des
conclusions au final si l'autre n'a pas
les éléments qui vous ont permis de
conclure ça d'arriver à cette conclusion
en fait vous ferez composé d des
conclusions qui sont une interjection
lancée et marc et autres dons qui lui
permet de réaction à ces tribunes à ce
que y'en a que tu trouve intéressante
car il ya pas mal de gars que tu sois
pas forcément intéressante mais chut tu
peux aussi
dans quelles sont les relations qu'ils
avaient les réactions qu'on a eu en fait
on a eu beaucoup de gens qui se
revendique enfin jeudi qui se revendique
parce que je connais pas personnellement
mais je me doute bien que s'ils le font
c'est pas pour apporter entre compétents
là dedans qui sera dit de
l'épistémologie est effectivement de la
place de la science de la place de la
science dans la société
l'interaction de la science avec la
société et la science telle qu'elle est
propre elle qu'elle est factuellement et
il y avait une la peine chaque de la
faim qui avaient assez assez mal
comprise j'ai l'impression là une
citation de pasteur king la science a
pas de patrie et à laquelle je répondais
avec un jeu de mots en disant qu'il ne
devrait pas donc l'avoir de parts de
parti pris idéologique
donc c'était c'était une punchline de
fin qui n'avait pas vocation à être
autre chose qu'un enjeu noé qui parlait
dans ma tête et dans la tête de pas mal
de fin de ceux à qui on a fait relire de
manière évidente en fait la science avec
la science avec un grand s ont fait la
science tels compter qu on l'idéalisé
parce que factuellement ces fois où la
science à des patries la science la
science se fait dans des pays avec des
contextes particuliers la science a
nécessairement des partis pris
idéologiques mais la science est un
petit assez et c'est vrai que du coup en
fait cette phrase là comme c'est
quasiment un cas d'école de choses qu'on
peut étudier en philosophie des sciences
en épistémologie comme c'est un cas
d'école en fait il ça alors c'est
pourquoi le débat sur le bien-fondé
cette phrase etc qui dans notre tête en
fait c'était vraiment une punchline
beaucoup plus qu'un argument un kit on
s'intéressait à la véracité de la phrase
en fait donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
mal comprise
ce que tu aurais dû y avoir mais je ne
pense pas en fait fin je pense qu'il
fallait dans tous les cas une punchline
conclusion un truc et on peut pas se
permettre de dire
donc voilà ça serait bien que les
rédactions format plus plusieurs
journalistes points si on avait dit ça
on aurait eu aucune force en fait
il fallait s que si quelqu'un trouve une
meilleure punchline va écouter
bon bah désolé voilà donc c'est ce qu'on
a trouvé là jamais elle n'a pas être
sûrement pas été dit en pensant concept
qu'on pense qu'on en pensant que la
science on a été exempte de bienne
personne ne pense à dents dans les vins
rédacteurs et je pense que je les
journées à parler pendant les
signataires occasion sa tasse et on les
a aussi choisi parce que lorsqu on les
connaissait un petit peu personnellement
il compensait que nous suivre là dedans
donc donc personne ne pense ça chez nous
on va ainsi cette année cela ne va pas
avant bras désolé enfin nous on sait
pourquoi on l'a mis tout ce qu'on peut
faire maintenant si vous expliquer
pourquoi on l'a mise si vous avez mieux
bah tant pis on a on aurait pu faire
mieux
mes meilleurs matches de sa sans regret
quoi on a on a fait ce qu'on a pu quoi
elle n'aura pas vingt sur vingt dix
turrado six injections de parce que l'on
n'a pas réduit en payant 6 2 jo rin des
des phrases
oui oui on était assez compliqué d'en
face est compliqué encore une fois
question à choix des équations à
résoudre dans tous les sens ah oui parce
qu'en fait ces phrases candidats n ont
pas vocation à convaincre le public
c'est à dire que si jamais vous avez été
biberonné parlera confions nucléaire
c'est incompatible avec avec l'enjeu
écologique qui se prépare et que vous
voyez cette phrase qui vous dit que
nucléaire tout ou partie de ceux qui
rejettent pas beaucoup de co2 par
rapport à la quantité d'énergie produite
si ça peut vous interrogez déclenché
nérac suez déclencher une réflexion
c'est très bien mais l'objectif n'est
pas que lorsque vous lisez cette phrase
je vous soyez toutacoo convaincu que
c'est vrai c'est que c'est pas ça
l'objectif est double du coût pour
cesser ce qui explique aussi qu'on n'a
pas fait des choses exhaustive on n'a
pas abordé l'intégralité de la question
du nucléaire on est partis du mix
énergétique
et la place du caire là dedans on n'a
pas du tout abordé l'intégralité des
questions qu'il faut se poser autour des
lm on est vraiment jeudi une question un
aspect très précis un petit peu voire
parfois complètement m'a traitée par les
médias ou des fêtes au plus tard dans le
débat public et a du coup là on n'est
pas sur quelque chose de d'exhaustif et
il fallait qu'on est du coup une phrase
vrai et du coup pour avoir une phrase
devrait en fait ça a demandé parfois de
de recourir à deux je n'ai pas envie
d'appeler ça les astuces puisque astuces
ça fait un peu floue et les gens mais
pour avoir une phrase vrai des fois il a
fallu se concentrait sur un aspect très
précis qu'on peut pas faire si on veut
dire que je devrais en étant ex aussi
bas en fait il faut revenir une tribune
de 15 pages quoi du coup pour être
factuel sur un aspect précis on a une
phrase qui est très courte qui parfois
en fait est à l'origine une citation
c'est le cas sur les ogm qui est une
citation exacte de des communications de
l'efsa c'est le cas sur l'homéopathie
qui est une citation aussi de caisse
exact je pense qu'aussi de d'une
communication d'une traduction que je
peux être je crois par l'ordre des
médecins ou le conseil national général
de je crois que c'est par l'autre des
médecins où la famille de séquencer
l'académie les cimes qui traduisait à
l'académie européenne de médecine et
nous paraissent cette phrase c'est aussi
une citation exacte du coup on fait
quand vous une citation exacte on avait
confiance que ce truc là voilà on
pouvait vous avez la référence derrière
qui n'avance plus institutionnel que que
scientifique qui vous avez ces
références qui vous verrez que voilà des
gens très sérieux ils le disent sous
cette forme là ils le disent qu'il n'y a
pas de preuve de l'efficacité de
l'homéopathie vladeta placebo et donc
c'est vrai que si sûr mais une réfection
complète là dessus tout peut-être le mot
preuve il est toujours sujet un petit
peu à débat et donc il pourrait être
formulée autrement mais on l'a laissé
comme ça parce que c'est
citation de l'académie nationale de
médecine et que du coup s'ils le disent
on s'est permis de le mettre comme ça la
phrase est pas elle est fausse si on
s'intéresse si on est très précis sur la
question mais le message à faire passer
sera compris la bonne manière il n'y a
pas de preuve pour les faits l'effet
propre de l'homme a dit que nous sommes
ça ça laisse quand même vachement
entendre que ya pas encore de preuves
pour beaucoup plus la porte que ce que
suggère vraiment les 29 ans au physique
darrigand gimmick et de nos petits crus
entièrement clairement mais du coup ils
nous pour assurer nos arrières pour dire
voilà on peut répondre aux gens qui
lisent pour que vous avez dit ça on peut
avoir le lien qui va voilà c'est dit
elle qui est là par l'académie nationale
de médecine
c'est l'avis aussi de tout autre de
plein d'autres académies partout dans le
monde m et alors bas en france ça a été
à la formule c'est à cette manière là si
on avait modifié sa on aurait fait on
craignait qu'on puisse nous attaquer sûr
c'est pas ça qui s'est passé avec une
académie c'est pas ça que les gens
disent que vous faites si c'est notre
propre phrase du coup il faut avoir une
réflexion beaucoup plus une question
beaucoup plus long sur pourquoi est ce
que ce sont ces mots là qu'ont utilisé
par d'autres et c est du coup en fait on
pensait au début que de mettre une
citation fait que nous couvrirait sur le
fait que non c'est pas nous qu'il soit
notre chapeau c'est comme ça que ses
dc10 en ces mots là effectivement c'est
me lasser ils sont aussi critiquable
mais du coup bon secours envoyés soit
très beau gosse sur deux choses et
beaucoup d'autres phrase pareille qui
pour être vrai son finissent par être un
petit peu bizarre et donner l'impression
à certains que qu'on essaie de les flous
et c'est dans le cadre des ogm du catch
plus proche
la phrase qu'on dit c'est le fait que 15
en galice soin génifique une plante par
exemple soit un ogm ne présentent pas de
danger pour
pour la santé etc actuellement vrai mais
dans les faits n'importe quel os j'aime
pas du mans on a fait une modification
ça serait ça serait utopique de dire que
n'ont rien changé parce que si on a
changé quelque chose
donc forcément on peut avoir des effets
qui sont imperceptibles personne recevra
dans la vie de tous les jours peut y
avoir des effets minimes mais dans les
faits il y aura toujours un petit
quelque chose en bien ou en mal
parce que par définition vient de
changer quelque chose
cette phrase pareille que peut donner
pour être vrai cette phrase doit vous
dire quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas une
grande praticité jeu juste lire la
phrase mais c'est le fait qu'un
organisme soit génétiquement modifiées
entre parenthèses ogm ne présentent pas
en soi de risque pour la santé
le cessna citation de sa douce et pas de
citations dans cette situation mais du
coup elle le en soit je sais que j'ai
fait lire ça plusieurs personnes et le
lensois donnait un peu l'impression d'un
certain que qu'on essayait de de nier
l'existence de faits de déportée quand
même de nier l'existence d' ogm qui
peuvent poser problème et c'est un petit
peu bizarre parce que chaque ogm il
faudra évaluer chaque ogm aura son
impact soit sur l'association plein de
trucs là il faut l'évaluer pour pour
chaque objet est donc de faire cette
phrase qui dit en soi allais-je apprécié
l'accueil y est ce que c'est si on n'a
pas si on n'a pas quinze pages en fait
faire une phrase ils soient vraies et
équité
facile est basse et ouais c'est assez
c'est un exercice de gymnastique assez
assez repas ensemble ouais parce
qu'après le truc qui est ce que tu
utilises la phrase sur une petite et une
situation moi parce que les dents dans
le texte n'est pas la balance
bénéfice-risque des principaux dans ma
part que l'expropriation des produits ou
roddick ou parce qu'il n'ya pas de
guillemets on sait pas quelle est cette
fois c'est comment on avait certains que
des citations à d'autres il n'était pas
comme on le fait jouer mais ce n'est pas
une citation le ski et sur le pâtis et
ce qui est également sûr à cause que je
pense le glyphosate
ce sont des citations exactes les
exactes et en fait ça savent et ils
discutent et moi je les avais laissés et
débuts en situation celle qui en sont et
pas citation c'est qu'ils n'en sont pas
et savent et le collectif collégialement
décidé qu on les mettrait tout sous la
même forme pour des soucis de clarté par
donner l'impression non médicaux subis
clarté du coup en fait les deux phrases
qui sont des citations c'est d'obliger
plus critiquée sur twitter bah c'est pas
notre choix de mots c'est le choix de
mots d'autres instances qui sont qui
sont pas très critique des circonstances
je pense que c'est il y aura il va en
vue chez moi de dire des trucs qui sont
à la fois beaucoup plus tranchées et
beaucoup plus rigoureuse que ça paraît
il à la tribune elle a uniquement pour
objectif ses phrases on sait qu'elles
sont simples sous pression n'est pas sur
le sujet des problèmes en mai on s'en
éloigne pas trop pour pour certains pour
certaines phrases sont absolument pas
vocation à devenir une bible l'objectif
c'est qu'ils soient des points de départ
et que les gens simplement se divertir
sur sur la question des ogm il ya au
moins un truc que une base de
scientifiques trouvent mal représentés
dans le débat lors duquel se trouve la
question de nous là dessus l'objectif
est pas de convaincre de l'enfer c'est
pas du tout l'événement à ce qu'on écrit
ouais
c'est c'est très intéressant que je
recommande fortement d'aller voir - la
tribune pour voir la collaboration de
plusieurs mois et je pense que soient
ses intérêts c'est important de se dire
que c'était compliqué à écrire parce que
c'était 40 écrire ah ouais et essayer de
voir aussi réfléchir parce que question
les meilleures manières de parler de
tous ces sujets là on est sûr de votre
mieux puissance confronté au real quoi
on est sur du débat tournait pas du tout
d'être ici ouais et est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres enseignements que tel que dans
ces antres de toi toi de maintenant
quelqu'un qui a vécu tout ça et il faut
avancer tribune bah en fait vraiment les
enseignements que je les tire du fait
qu'on a eu des réflexions et du coup
c'est assez compliqué d'anticiper
dessous du combat mon conseil serait
anticipée dans les fonctions que vous
ferez bien conscience que ce n'est pas
un conseil facilement applicables donc
entourez-vous d'un maximum de gens après
pareille toi et ça j'adore le carnet d
adresses trouver les bonnes personnes
très bons conseils aux personnes de sa
viande et cp ce qui se passera au futur
développé un petit nombre de vies nation
franchement je vous jure ça vous aidera
est ce que tu penses que tu avais où
vous aviez sous-estimé la difficulté je
sais pas je crois pas parce qu'en fait
on l'a vécu la difficulté plus que
estimer ou sous-estimé en fait ouais
c'est à dire que on a fait chaque étape
l'une après l'autre et à chaque étape on
a constaté les difficultés et les points
2 des points de difficulté simplement
donc quand on a plus constaté la
difficulté que qu'anticipé ou pas ou on
la plupart d'entre nous n'avons pas
l'expérience de sage qu'on a un ou deux
vétérans de la tribu des 124 et qui sont
pas je crois pas tu peux pas dire si
parmi les signataires je sais
et a beaucoup et on la sent expérience
en fait on a surtout on l'a on l'a vécu
difficulté à anticiper et du coup quand
est ce que tu veux le futur de tout ça
c'est la grande question en fait parce
que typiquement les choix qu'on a fait
ce sont des choix qui ont pour vocation
de taper du poing sur la table et
d'appeler à une réponse assez rapide et
28 mois sur un truc en tête
je crois que j'ai oublié ce que je
voulais dire si par exemple dans le dans
les cibles qu'on avait publiquement ses
phrases simples frais et des phrases en
fait ça nous avait aussi parfois été
reproché par ce qu'on peut pas être
exhaustif sur deux choses à sauf que en
fait ce qu'on ne voulait surtout pas
c'était c'est pas d'exemple et que du
fait qu'il n'ya pas d'exemple on est des
gens qui par exemple sont tout à fait
d'accord sur le constat du changement
climatique mais qui derrière son dans un
milieu pourquoi pas militant pourquoi
pas chaude familiale ils ont appris que
les ogm c'est tous de la merde que les
fauchés c'est faire le bien c'est
vraiment être un paladin de la justice
de faucher des ogm de tout détruire et
de ne rien laisser passer
et du coup ça on voulait surtout pas
qu'il y avait une personne comme ça par
exemple se disent tiens prenez ça dans
votre gueule et les climato sceptiques
il faut se passer sur la science sans
réaliser que que lui aussi en fait on
n'aurait pas le même réflexe pas le même
reproche à lui faire
mais aussi pourquoi pas un reproche sur
un sur un cas particulier et du coup ça
marche dans les deux sens en fait on
voulait surtout pas que cette tribune
soit q7 être que tous puissent se la
réapproprier en choisissant un petit peu
le le côté où il se fit au cursus
scientifiques et les côtés où il a son
opinion personnelle qu'il estime
supérieur au consensus scientifique et
donc donc pour nous il fallait des
exemples il fallait des exemples pour
surtout pas qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation on a une tribune qui peut être
signé par tout le monde qui dit
simplement que bah oui dans l'action
c'est cool qui faisait respecter et et
ça on voulait pas parce que sinon
effectivement son binôme de signataires
potentiel en france à metz
il sera passé quoi et donc du coup il
fallait des exemples il fallait des
exemples un peu pour tout le monde alors
on aurait peut-être pu tâter le plus
large mais bon c'est le choix d'exemple
est aussi liée aux personnes qui ont
rédigé la tribune ouais il fallait
absolument d exemple il fallait pas
qu'on soit dans une situation où chacun
puisse la lire comme il veut et où il
fallait du coup il du coup le truc ce
qu'on voulait faire donner au moins un
petit taquet à tout le monde dans tous
les sens et tout le monde se dit voilà
si c'est pas d'accord avec tout ça c'est
aussi pour ça pour ça qu'il est là la
métaphore du supermarché c'est à dire
voilà si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
tout bas c'est qu'il ya au moins un côté
sur lequel vous avez au minimum des
réserves sur ce qui est plus ou moins le
consensus scientifique pour ce que
consensus veut dire c'est le prêt mais
définir les récits je vais commencer une
présentation à 10 ans et cognitif de
points c'est qu'ils empêchent les autres
de bien réfléchir je taisais reaser de
l'asie à varetz et s'applique à moi
aussi
voilà confie on voulait que tout le
monde encore un petit peu trop gras dont
paul est pas ciblé une personne je pense
pas qu'ils aient une personne qui fait
un sacré illuminé pour avoir faut
surtout les points qui sont là je pense
il ya au moins un point qui le contrait
conforter qu'elle présente voilà il faut
que tout le monde se rend compte qu'il
ya des choses sur lesquelles on est bien
informé des chaussures est peut-être pas
super bien informés et qui a une
réflexion à fournir là dessus parce que
s'il ya un sentiment partagé parmi les
parmi les scientifiques de tous horizons
confondus que ce soit en biologie en
sciences sociales en sociologie en
astrophysique et si un sentiment partagé
que on peut mieux faire
peut-être que ça vaut la peine qu'on les
écoute ses doléances et et qu'on fasse
quelque chose
ac c'est le gros problème plus jardin de
la transférabilité qu'on apprend des
trucs dans un domaine
et c'est très difficile on peut avoir
appris la méthode scientifique ou jeux
pas trop qua non pour un cas et puis
dans un entretien au pape en série est
appliquée parce que ça en sorte de
contexte et en vivre mais là je peux
faire ce que je veux oui oui c'est ça il
ya des fois même même les scientifiques
ne sont pas du tout les ans à des
situations difficiles comme exactement
ce que dit on apprend à raisonner avec
vos chances du logis j'appréhende des
choses rien de logique
c'est quand même le cancérologue qui
vaut des concerts partout c'est on a on
a une façon il ya un pan de la méthode
scientifique qui s'applique
particulièrement à notre domaine de
compétence
cependant là on le maîtrise franchement
pas trop j'espère franchement pas trop
mal j'espère que c'est arrivé de son
doctorat commencé à nous tous un petit
peu mais mes parents directement sur
d'autres domaines
bah comme on n'a pas les outils bas du
cou spontanément on considère que c'est
plus la science comme on le ferait nous
et que du coup bas effectivement on peut
se permettre des opinions 1
du coup et on sait ce que ça soit
beaucoup même dans les dab odeur de
biologie je suis pas du che sur sur tous
les gens que j'ai pu croiser ces
dernières années mais vous trouverez
aussi même dans l'est parmi les docteurs
et tout ce que vous voulez des gens qui
sur d'autres sujets sur le sujet de
l'égalité homme femme tue le sujet de
sur d'autres sujets l'astrophysique qui
vont avoir des idées farfelues et sans
doute l'hommage en est sûr je suis
convaincu que j'en ai sur deux ou trois
sujets qui sont pas derrière je vous
serais même pas mal de scientifiques qui
en lisant les trucs votre tribune ont
découvert que beaucoup dans la société
bic qui va à l'encontre de voir en pole
position
ah oui si vous signez pour les
scientifiques et qu'ils savaient pas
plus lente et tous les gens qui se
revendique de la science qui se
revendique éclairer sur ces sujets -
ballon contré par pression je parle
beaucoup dans mon lit mettions les
probabilités cessé même pas juste penser
c'est un truc que j'ai un peu appris à
l'école puis je faisais en thèse même
que les gosses ont profité dans ma thèse
mais c'est un truc que je pensais pas
appliquée en dehors de ma recherche
vendoire de tingwick quotidienne foyer
je veux savoir lire l'interview ci est
resté fan de bob
psychologue des sciences aussi est qui
qui j'ai aussi bas avec des cônes et
typhons les apprentis sont très
théoriques et on les applique dans la
recherche on raisonne par rapport à sam
et enfin on oublie le soir en rentrant
chez soi que on a aussi nos biais
cognitif et que toute la théorie qu'on
développe s'applique elle même c'est si
on a tendance à compartimente alizés
dire oui c'est ça dans un tel cas oui je
suis en contact scientifique gis
application cbi dans telle autre cave on
va mettre domaine scientifique le reste
donc je deviens citoyen comme un autre
et puis et puis malheureusement se
permet les bonnes vieilles que ceux qui
sont pas informés alors que alors qu'on
est passé par huit ans d'études
j'ai très rapidement le bouclier ton
beaucoup du coup cette semaine peut-être
un autre pan de cette tribune c'est je
trouve ça un peu dommage
personnellement que l'on entend dans la
tribune lui manque c'est très difficile
de ne pas avoir mis en difficulté la
complexité du problème parce que souvent
quand si on n'est pas un peu dans le
milieu et on peut faire un truc sur les
ogm
si on s'appuie sur internet marc 8 c'est
tellement cette question a eu la
difficile accessibilité des infos
fiables qu'on aime avoir ça il est juste
de s'informer de façon générale dans les
premières versions la tribune ont parlé
un petit peu de
de formation des journalistes
d'interaction d'interaction journaliste
scientifique dans la version finale
je crois qu'il reste plus que l'appel à
être dans la main mais il a été grossi
c'est vrai que ça c'est ça c'est comment
ça je pense que tel qu'on l'envisagé le
débat qu'il faut avoir à partir de
maintenant ça que ces tribunes doit être
le départ
si l'exemple haute et bien choisi a
priori le débat sur les exemples il va
falloir le ter assez rapidement et
passer à que faire pour la suite et
typiquement ça ça va là dessus est la
nouvelle page suite est basse et ça
c'est maintenant comment faire parce que
là on a fait le diagnostic la voiture
les casses et tape du poing sur la table
pour dire il faut la réparer rapidement
parce que c'est pas tenable et
maintenant fausse parce qu'ils ont de
comment ça peut être soit au travers
d'interaction journal et scientifique ça
peut être au travers de la formation de
journaliste et là-dessus pareils à des
journalistes ils acceptent très bien
qu'il dise qu'on veut être plus fort
mais on vient tous quitte avec un
journaliste qui qui se plaignait du
manque de formation qu'ils avaient et
parfois des journaliers ce qui n'est pas
qu'ils prennent c'est très compliqué de
dire à quelqu'un vous n'êtes pas assez
formés fois déjà quand même quand c'est
en vain qu'on sait votre boss ou un
employeur potentiel qui vous dit ça en
général en c1 c'est une critique assez
dur à prendre à prendre dans la gueule
alors quand en plus c'est des random sur
internet qui vous disent désolés vous
n'êtes pas assez formés à profit dès que
vous serez des trucs je comprends que ça
puisse déclencher des réactions peu en
plus épidermique c'est très compliqué de
deux prétendent avoir c'est se dire
cette autorité sur ses pas une autorité
sur les gens c'est de prétendre être en
position de dire à un tel que vous
n'êtes pas fort mais qu'ont donc le
comment le comment réussir à faire
comprendre ça faire accepter sa part
plus de demandes que les journalistes
qui sont aujourd'hui sont signataires
des journalistes qui sont venus
spontanément nous voir on a eu on a eu
beaucoup de surprises en fait on a eu
plusieurs journalistes qui sont venus
nous voir qu'ils voulaient écrire des
trucs et presque à chaque fois les
journalistes
ils nous ont demandé des sources on a vu
dans l'arctique finale qui mettait les
sources enfin en bas de page ils nous
ont demandés ils nous ont proposé les
artic la relecture avant ça qu'ils ont
pris ils ont pris du retard sur la
publication d'articles en cuir le
lendemain les plus tard 6 en ligne
ils ont pris du retard pour nous le
faire relire pour demander s'il avait
écrit des trucs factuellement faux et on
a été extrêmement agréablement surpris
pas ça en fait c'est parce que c'est
clairement ce ce pourquoi on milite
d'abord des avoirs des articles enfin en
bas de page des journaux
ce qui est très rarement le cas
aujourd'hui je pense qu'avec des fois
j'ai vu un truc en plus qui était assez
presque cocasse qui était il ya deux
trois semaines une fin au journal que
l'opacité qui publiait une petite règle
quelque chose sur encore un peu plus un
type un petit peu plus technique sur un
cas médical qu'on ait trouvé etc et qui
faisait référence à une étude dans le
très célèbre de 27 et il avait mis un
lien il a fait défaut remettra ils ont
mis un lien sur deux 27
il met sur le renvoi de la page
d'accueil du journal ça on peut la voir
une recherche google total de 9,5 et qui
ont l'âme et une étude six mois que ce
que c'est l'étude quoi qu'on puisse
aller la voir et donc ça c'est ça c'est
je pense que c'est un point sur lequel
on glisse qui ne demande pas qui ne
manque pas une grande formation ou juste
comprendre que quand on avance une idée
dont pas ça peut être un rite orial mais
qu on avance à un chiffre quand on dit
voilà la réalité ces cinq bars vent il
faut que tu me donnes une source qui me
disent ouais effectivement le 5 c'est
pas c'est par intel qui vont à coup de
coude et un comptoir a dit au choix que
c'est simple c'est c'est le résultat
soit d'une réflexion pertinente
philosophes ou autre nous soit une
conclusion dans ce pilote d'une
conclusion après une étude plus
sérieuses le 5 passes et brasser une
conclusion d'un cheminement de pensée
on espère un nouveau type de logique
dont on pense qu'ils étaient
méthodologique plus que à une opinion
peut donner quoi aller chiffres si vous
balancer un chiffre vous le source et le
chiffre s'il vous plaît
allez c'est cette relation est pas sans
rappeler un truc qui se passe aussi en
ce moment qui me prive de article dans
nature de statisticiens qui cherche à
modifier
oui c'est lui qui disent que la plus
value que c'est de la merde ouais j'aime
bien sûr je me suis beaucoup
scientifiques sont pas très présents
mais moi je vois alors je suis pas un
grand fan de la nuit venue pour le coup
je pense que c'est quand même je pense
comme beaucoup devront pas assez
réfléchi à l'utilisation d'api value et
et moi en tout cas lequel il ya une
analogie à ces entrefaites que les
statisticiens essayé de parler aux
scientifiques de la même façon que vous
essayez de parler des simples ans et
parfois aussi que là il est un peu dans
le même sens où la route est sûre elle
demande de davantage de rigueur dans
l'analyse et paul sartre ça c'est un
truc que j'ai constaté aussi pas mal en
licence ou un master c'est que les stats
c'est pas un truc auquel on est très
fort mais ça va passer à son aile passer
ce coup mais c'est pareil il y avait pas
mal de stats donc finisse avec un gros
arbre de stades fin de la nar
décisionnel de quels tests quelles
conditions à quel point qu'elle était
dans quel ordre et ses rapports portes à
cannes pour répondre à quelques
questions
je sais qu'en licence de bio a des stats
on a fait les fisher et puis une étude n
quoi est elle si qui doit les tubes jan
fischer qui 2 et puis et puis c'est plié
et puis à vous demanderez à votre labo
comment ils font et puis en fait la bo à
tous les coups c'est quelqu'un qui est
parée de demander aux précédents et puis
les couilles déteste ça c'est vraiment
une compétence qui a assez peu dans les
en je peux parler au moins pour la
biologie que j'ai rarement retrouver des
gens qui sont vraiment des
les experts en statistiques qui est
capable de faire dire que pourtant c'est
essentiel satistiques ce que c'était pas
force est eastick jaton design
expérimental le commente a conçu ton
expérience comment tu anticipes plutôt
expérience se passera il va dépendre de
ce qui est pertinent comme la liste des
données en science la science histoire
et ça s'était produit les données avant
les analyser mais en général il faut que
tu pues celui qui a fait cette citation
que j'aime beaucoup nourri cercles ou
demander un scepticisme d'analysé des
données après avoir fait l'expérience un
peu comme demander à un médecin légiste
quoi est-ce qu'on est mort quoi mais
c'est au mieux et pourra vous dire de
courant des morts de quoi il a relancé
martin je voulais rester fisher mais ce
t-shirt permettra sûrement parce que
c'était sûr par contre c'est discuter
cybergo qu'armand il faut intégrer
l'esprit c'est d'ici qu'est la réflexion
de son garage et c'est vrai que ces
raisons il est essentiel des analogies
entre les scientifiques et envers le
regard des médias la chaîne
d'information des médias au public et
puis c'est qu'ils sont là je pense qu'il
ya une façon intéressante d'interpeller
assure ainsi une vidéo qui a l'air
d'avoir bien marché pour interpeller les
gens c'était sûr parler un peu de
psychologie et le fait que la méthode
dattebayo oui sélection la loi de
regarder la conduit à des choses qui
sont vraiment embêtante cas et bonjour à
une autre vidéo parents qui s'en servent
à ça c'est vraiment très très bon
exemple
j'aurais souhaité que la baisse de
température
j'aurais de dijon qui ont pu enfin
l'impliquant c'est un peu bêtement même
pas bêtement fait très probablement
aujourd'hui la majorité des publications
scientifiques sont à la suisse ou en
tout cas wave ou même être très soit peu
schématique soit un petit peu à côté de
la plaque et fois qu'une vidéo c'est une
provocation appréciation sur le toit du
lieu du crime oui que en sciences en
fait la plus value est très souvent
surestimés et qu'au final de portions
typhi qui
c'est mon avis je parle pour moi je
parle puisque je pense je pense que la
plus les meilleurs scientifiques sont
ceux qui prêtent pas attention à qui
value et et qu'au final tous une
expérience du une bonne expérience écran
sur lequel tu vas pouvoir te baser en
fait tu sais que tu vas trouver un
résultat qui t'intéresse un protocole
qui était développée par intel qui est
intéressant tu mets en place
s'il marche tant mieux s'il marche pas
tu t'en fiches et la petite value la
plus value est là elle n'intéresse et
scientifique en fait aujourd'hui qu au
moment de publier en fait mais c'est
parce que c'est plus ou moins la règle
d'avoir d'avoir des belle plus value est
plus basse possible avant de réussir à a
publié alors qu'au final ce qui va
compter c'est est ce que ton expérience
servira aux suivants quoi ouais c'est un
indicateur mais il ya beaucoup de choses
à prendre en compte oui c'est un
indicateur quoi c'est mais c'est pas une
réponse en fait débat y déploie on voit
on voit ça ce soit chez de jaunisse mais
aussi parfois chez chez les
scientifiques
j'espère qu'en tout cas ça pas longtemps
après les études ça comme ça commence à
se fermer pendant les études je n'ai vu
encore qui résonnait comme ça qu'ils
aillent aux affaires à 5%
c'est prouvé non du tout
et des fois ça se retrouve des gens qui
soient des jeunes j'espère que c'est que
les jeunes chercheurs à ou parfois des
actes de la science qui sont à la
recherche de la plus value de dents
aiguisées ok c'est bon cette information
là je la prends c'est acté et que je
peux la notte elle est bonne non
c'est une expérience à d'ailleurs on a
de bonnes raisons de penser que ce n'est
pas le hasard
ouais et alors je mangeais pas pas
s'avancer plus loin que ça et des yeux
je trouve qu une stratégie qui a été
acquis et ses intéressante poissy de
montrer que c'est vraiment un problème
c'est sans parler des conséquences de de
fin du niveau de rigueur actuellement
utilisé par l'emprunt science a par
exemple le fait que la majorité des za
des articles publiés du coup sont
possiblement très fallacieux et de la
même façon je pense que dans le cas du
journalisme je pense que les sorties qui
essaie d'appliquer la paix va louer
notre sentier qui cherche avant tout à
bien faire les essais vraiment de
contribuer mais ils ont des contraintes
de temps devait s'incliner sur la
définition de la job quoi et je pense
que laval la même remarque qui nous
remarque très similaires s'applique aux
journalistes c'est une commission de
médication puis ils ont l'impression que
ce qu'ils font est suffisamment
rigoureux il ya sans doute un manque de
prise en compte de la malléabilité des
méthodes qu'ils utilisent et du coup du
raisonnement motivés et dé tous les
biais psychologiques mais on m'a très
bien mais c'est aussi parce que doc on
va faire scientifique ou journaliste est
compliquée et difficile voire de choses
nous c'est les éditeurs c'est leur
incontournable
il se voit contrainte quand c'est
compliqué bachand forcément des erreurs
mais je pense que c'est important
d'avoir un objectif un peu plus
longtemps en tête et se dire bon bah
finalement le but de tout ça c'est quoi
je vois qu'ils étaient de faire avancer
la connaissance selon que l'on pouvait
faire une tribune dans ce sens là on
pourrait après la première à destination
des journalistes on pourrait se
retourner vers les éditeurs et que leur
dire arrêtez de nous casser les couilles
avec la clé
parce que c'est aussi une des raisons
pour laquelle derrière des reproches à
faire un peu plus loin dans la chaîne de
l'information a montré dans toute la
chaîne et quelques choses à améliorer
oui d'ailleurs menacé la semaine est il
écrit sa tribune le feu a pris
après il ya un truc est menée dans
nature oui possible par 800 signataires
sont difficiles mais ce qu'elle était
vraiment à destination des éditeurs ou
des journalistes a donc il ya donc ça
s'est épuisé dans nos coeurs c'était
plus la distillation des scientifiques
c'est ce que j'ai l'impression après il
ya aussi d'autres travaux fait sa sortie
en même temps qu'une édition spéciale de
diamagueune statisticiens ou ou a eu
cinquante quatre publications autour de
rennes 2 p value et a beaucoup qui a en
particulier qui ciblait beaucoup les
éditeurs envie d'en avoir
l'éditeur ont un pouvoir énorme lors des
passes que les scientifiques à pozo
publish or perish nobis un peu aux
éditeurs et ses éditeurs sont demande
plus de rigueur
ça changera le jeu des scientifiques
beaucoup la qualité de la publication
scientifique complètement bon
dessinateur n'est pas l'emploi va revoir
ses envies d'en avant de malheureusement
compliqué beaucoup d'acteurs et beaucoup
de choses à améliorer
c'est pas facile bondoukou pour la suite
la prochaine étape des élections
comment est-ce qu'on confirme ça c'est
une grosse question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on confirme les sept si on peut se
dire qu on essaie au moins il ya un
petit des big débat de quelque chose
s'entourer de journalistes faire ces
changements étaient ce qu'il faut est ce
que tu en penses quoi je connais je
serai pas très bien le monde
journalistique je remplis mieux placé
pour dire quelles sont les meilleures
relations à fort avec les journalistes
mais de ce que je comprends avec hamdi a
des relations entre nous et je pense que
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas mal de
bonne volonté même du côté journée de
lundi s'appuyer dessus pas clairement
mais ouais mais coup après les bonnes
relations qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est des
bonnes relations qu'on avait avant en
fait et alors on a découvert deux foyers
de plus qui sont rapprochés de nous
après beaucoup on découvre une nouvelle
tête
mais j'ai pas une conviction absolue
qu'il y ait un journaliste qui avant
étaient six avants se disait maintenant
je mon travail est irréprochable et qui
tout à coup se dit à bientôt peut-être
que je fais des bêtises et enfin tiana
mais il peut diriger dans leur coin
justice vont pas s il serait tant mieux
et mais je parle j'ai pas par le
sentiment que la tribune a ni vocation
ni aura pour effet que des journalistes
peut-être les plus jeunes
ta télé rigueur les nouvelles
générations de journalistes s'ils s'y
voit ce jour deux tribunes pendant leurs
études
j'espère que ça peut être un tient
peut-être que ce qui est pas un petit
master 2 à faire quelque part un petit à
petit double cursus pour devenir plus
compétents dans tel ou tel domaine là il
peut être pour les plus jeunes peut-être
que commencer pour échanger sinon les
journalistes plaies les plus actes et
ceux qui nous aiment et pas spécialement
on leur a pas reparlé on a eu deux trois
journées très critique envers m à la
tribune avec qui on a eu la chance de
pouvoir parler face à face on verra pas
reparlé depuis la tribune
je ne sais pas si ils ont changé sinon
l'objectif c'est aussi de toucher les
les rédactions des tribunes au final
puisque comme le problème est aussi un
plus systémique que de mauvaise volonté
il n'y a pas de je connais pas
personnellement de journaliste je ne
crois pas qu'ils valent ans qu'on
discute du conseil scientifique en se
disant ils ont tous tort c'est moi qui
ai raison je sens que j'en connais pas
des comme ça donc mais il rêvait mais
les rédactions je pensais peut-être le
principal
notre principale cible ici mais en fait
ils sont capables de se dire et peu
limite que les journalistes puissent
aussi se servir de tribune est allé voir
leurs recruteurs donné de voir leur
employeur en disant voilà ça c'est ce
qu'on pense à ce que les gens pensent
les scientifiques pensent que j'enlève
sortie sud en france donc pas si c'est
ce que ça c'est ce que ça ne crée pas
intéressant que j'aille faire ou que
d'envoyer des petits des journalistes de
la rédaction à faire des faire des
stages faire des c'est pas des
formations au journalisme scientifique
pour que soit la méthode ou la méthode
scientifique ou alors à un domaine si un
journaliste qui est spécialisée je parle
de reprise et qui est bas
cette puce puisse aller voir son
employeur en disant voilà ce qu'on peut
pas citer peuple est ce qu'on peut pas
se tenir dans la rédaction se risque pas
d'avoir des gens plus qu'en mai
qu'actuellement et donc notre public
cible c'est vraiment les rédactions plus
que c'est le systémique plus que les
individus parce que je fais confiance
aux journalistes pour pas auprès des
idiots je pense que si si si voie bleue
gérer c'est cette citation de
saint-exupéry si vous voulez donner
envie eux
si vous voulez que des gens construisent
un radeau beau donner leur envie d'aller
explorer l'horizon que l'objectif un peu
oui
si vous voulez ce les peuples formez vos
journalistes à envoyer des informations
à ne leur coûtait pas la pression la
rédaction a fait dix minutes après une
dépêche afp
je pense que ce soit j'imagine que pas
mal de journée jusqu'à lundi date du
journalisme de ce mois c'est de tendre
vers sap devenez ça comme objectif de
bons journalistes du tiw mans et
j'envoie voir parce que c'est oui et
puis réfléchir à pas mal à ça et puis
c'est à dire que pour me tende vers
sabha va falloir faire quelques étapes
par mégarde de rigueur ça peut servir à
ça franchement il c'est un tribunal et
voir les employeurs et il dit lors que
vous aussi vous avez envie de cette
époque kouakou et puis va nous aussi on
essaiera de faire notre part du boulot
avec aux histoires d'édition et de
commandes de comment on communique watch
l'aï la tribune importante pour les tout
ce qui est de médiation communications
scientifiques par des scientifiques par
des vulgarisateurs scientifiques par des
gens une scientifique et tous en général
ce que je pense que c'est un sujet qui
est négligée ou non
je pense qu'il ya qui est négligée on
n'a pas le temps d'attendre sa pas
suffisamment réfléchir à quelles sont
les meilleures façons de communiquer le
consensus scientifique
il ya des sites d'exercices sur à quoi
ressemble mon métier il ya dix ans et
puis bah je suis formé au métier que
fait que les formateurs ont connu qu'au
final je suis formé à ce qui se passe à
yala il ya trente ans mais par exemple
la phrase il n'existe aucune preuve de
l'effet pourquoi produit lui placé deux
de nos pâtit si c'est si justin pas
assez réfléchi à cette phrase que je
pense parce que si on réfléchit à cette
phrase je pense qu'il ya de quoi être
extrêmement critiqué mme hou là là je
parle de vue que c'est une situation
c'est hauteur de la situation et du coup
celle-ci pape cissé l'académie nationale
de médecine excitait il traduisait un
rapport de l'académie européenne
toutes ces académies des sciences
il fallait y compris au xylophone et
c'est tout tout ça je pense qu'ici une
réflexion à avoir
chez eux aussi sais pas s'il y en a qui
travaillent chez eux qui nous écoute
mais aussi d'avoir une réflexion sur
quelles sont les meilleures façons de
communiquer les consensus scientifique
parce que je pense qu'il ya des progrès
énormes à faire notamment parce qu'on
n'y a pas suffisamment réfléchi et que
c'est un problème complexe parce qu'il
faut comme disait anticiper les mêmes
manière dont les joueurs vont réagir à
telle ou telle formulation et c'est ça
qui importe c'est la réaction des gens
c'est pas tant est-ce que ce qui est dit
est vrai ce qui est est ce que ça va ou
pas senti cette pratique si on veut un
changement faut se concentrer sur les
effets couvent dans nos actions plus que
c'est votre réflexion quoi donc donc je
pense que c'est or c'est un beau départ
d'un bon point de départ pour pour plus
de fric c'est ce qu'on espère en tout
cas cessé leur festif c'est ce qu'on
espérait
je pense que j'ai touché à peu près tous
les points des dodgers
je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas
qu'est-ce que
est-ce qu'on aurait quelque chose à
proposer factuellement nous on avait
réfléchi à s'interroger sur la
pertinence d'avoir une espèce de
d'annuaire deux recueils de
scientifiques accessibles comme il y en
a pas mal sur twitter on s'était dit que
est ce que ce serait pertinent que nous
on se met à faire un espèce de
d'annuaires où on pourrait réorienter
les journalistes qui ont des questions
vers untel ou untel dont la communauté
dans laquelle la communauté on va dire à
confiance et qui pourraient et dont la
parole pourrait pas falloir consensus
mais pas il va falloir quand même
opinion éclairée par ce que parce que
des fois c'est un festival problème
aussi c'est que commence jeudi la
publication comme on idéalise en fait la
publication comme étant celle qui
apporte la preuve on se dit pas si ces
écrivains publication et la publication
à l'air sérieuses on peut se permettre
d'affirmer alors que encore une fois on
va reparler de prati qualité ce qui
compte c'est ce que l'étude en fête a
été utile aux scientifiques pour
développer leur conception de leurs
domaines de jeu travail quoi ce sur quoi
ils travaillent donc si jamais cette
étude est la boîte très belle mais en
vrai s'applique à rien et puis les
scientifiques ont pas changé leur façon
d'aborder la question va en fait
interroger scientifique en fait bien
vrai il encore la question des questions
efficace et roger parce que encore une
fois quand on va on va en prendre un ou
hasard si un réel consensus
on peut estimer qu'il ya peut-être des
bonnes chances que l'on finisse qu'on
tombe sur quelqu'un qui va suivre de
près la voie du consensus
mais si c'est un truc un peu dissonant
bas on va très rapidement se retrouver à
leur tour g1 ouazar puis ça se trouve
ils prêchent inverse de ce qu on
comprendra être vrai à la suite où nous
la vendre à une vision d'un truc qui est
très débattue donc nous on les voit ci
est ce que ça aurait été pertinent pour
face l'espèce d'annuaire et que les
journalistes
il tape dans cet annuaire ben voilà on
aurait aimé parler de tels problèmes et
puis plus rapidement dans la journée on
puisse trouver un tel qui est soit un an
plus tôt soit quelqu'un de très
accessible par mail qui est compétent
dans ce domaine et ont fourni du coût
des agressions comme ça
est ce que ce serait pertinent peut-être
est-ce que ça s'est compliqué sans doute
mais on en train de fois qu'on est en
train de réfléchir à ça si la bêtise
c'est ce que tu vois d'autre choix de
lingerie de rebondir sur deux choisit le
premier c'est que du coup ci c'est super
important je pense que dans 7 ans cet
annuaire de même en amont claude d'avoir
une relation warrants de bienveillance
envers les autres ah oui je t'attaque
tibet bienveillance et parce que pour un
joueur et ce sera même moi quand je vais
relire mes scripts sait si c'est plus
facile de demander à quelqu'un qui est
très sympa très rigoureux mais très
sympa aussi créé de demander à quelqu'un
qui va vraiment être chiant qui va
réguler pour une virgule pas importante
bienveillant c'est d'autant plus
important pour le game 2 de confiance et
malheureusement j'ai eu certains
échanges avec certains auteurs il ya
perdu à l'exercice signataires on va
dire de la tribune qui n'était pas du
niveau de bienveillance que espérons
pour espérer que je pourrais espérer
mois et encore moins 15 journalistes
pour paris à envisager d'avoir résolu
donc je pense est super important de
trait sur la brouille bienveillance ça
et de faire gaffe à ça et puis l'autre
point sur lequel veut réagir c'est aussi
là tu parlais d'un scientifique
interviews et qui mettrait paris en
bouteille sont ma vie sont sa dernière
marche en avant plutôt que le consensus
scientifique et je pense que c'est ça
arrive très très souvent malheureusement
il faut faire très attention aux
scientifiques et je pense qu'il ya un
besoin de former des scientifiques à ou
habitués puces et scientifique a quand
ils prennent des paroles publiques pas
prisé par le public bat parler avant
tout due du consensus de skins us
bouquet souligné qu'une idée et
consensuelle versus d'autres idées qu'il
souhaite c'est des choses que que
j'avais vu que c'est là la tribu c'était
la vidéo de stéphane demol qui commence
à faire ça et quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit mais oui bien sûr ça tous bien
sûr donc on a chaque fois que ce soit
par une parole lui maintenant il va le
faire avec un petit un petit niveau de
preuve affiché en dalles d'écran mais
bien sûr ce truc là faut le faire tout
le temps tout le temps c'est d'après une
étude c'est pas la même chose que oui
c'est vrai des décennies de publications
avoir été une compréhension a mené par
dessiner contre d'explication c'est pas
c'est pas la même chose et tout ça il
faut absolument qu'on qu'on le fasse
les journalistes comme nous ouais je
mens risqués comme les scientifiques
comme des médiateurs experts jeu
réalisateur on peut faire ce reproche
pas aussi de vous parler de divertir là
il s'est passé si fait prendre prendre
une étude scientifique comme une
dernière dépêche afp qu il faut qu il
faut que le premier a balancé sur sur
les réseaux sur les médias pour battre
pour avoir sa part d'attention
ouais je pense toujours prennent de
l'intelligence artificielle où il ya un
gros débat autour du mythe de la
singularité est ce qu'ils ont une
cinglée tel nom est tellement de
scientifiques vont de données que leur
avis sur cette question alors qu'il y
ait des sondages qui ont eu lieu il ya
c'est ce que les communautés pense que
c'est ça qui devrait avoir plus de
valeur
oui c'est pas si ça devrait avoir peur
mais ça devrait au moins être cité un
certain point
oui donc oui c'est vrai que parfois
aussi ça arrive ça quand on a une
opinion une opinion
on sait qui est inconscient scientifique
on sait que notre opinion un peu à
l'encontre et on est comme on est
convaincus de nos raisons veut pas aller
dans le sens du consensus pour ne
parlera que notre opinion way
alors que on sait qu'il ya eu un
consensus et que ce serait beaucoup plus
intéressant d'avoir du consensus était
de dire pourquoi on n'est pas d'accord
avec ça mais au final vous aurez fait
passer votre message que de chercher à
gré comme si comme si on avait peur que
si on donnait la version du consensus
tout d'un coup notre opinion vendre et
moi est vraiment écoutés et que l'autre
et ouais non c'est ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
et si vous savez qu'il ya un consensus
abords des lieux puis ensuite et
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas d'accord et
s'armer d'un consensus
je pense commencer par un esprit qu'est
ce qu'on peut lire je sais pas
on croise les doigts que ça se passe
bien on était tous un petit peu à cran
dans les premiers jours avec avec les
réactions qu'ils aient pu avoir parfois
épidermique parfois très intéressante
on voulait pas que les épidermique
prennent le dessus sur les intéressantes
je pense que même temps de souffler un
petit peu mais le sang a pu redescendre
la température et bah maintenant s est
méfiant mais c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et c'est
pareil
venez nous voir sur twitter sur vous
voulez si vous avez des idées de choses
pertinentes à faire avec cet objectif en
tête d'améliorer l'information faut
qu'on travaille là-dessus pour montrer
qu'on cherche à être main dans la main
autant que possible à travailler tous
ensemble
s'il y en a qui se sont sentis floués
par ce qui s'était fait représenter par
là désolé pour lui explique le début
c'est plus dans la question de l'écart
et l'adresse qu'une question de choix
tous ceux qui ont une méthode
scientifique s'est passé au point de vue
je sais pas je sais pas si les gens qui
réfléchissent à la philo des sciences
ont une question là dessus une langue de
prima tu mets mon point de vue c'est pas
le c'est pas le sujet qui fait la
science et la méthode scientifique
il n'y a que ça qui existent au final on
appelle science qui suit m est un
scientifique c'est pas si nous
produisons ça je sais pas s'il ya des
gens plus intelligents plus intelligents
que moi comme un péché dessus je pense
que des gens comme après chelsea et je
connais pas leur avis ouais donc là pour
qu'on venait
la peur de personne vous veut vous veut
dans la réflexion faut qu'on fasse
passer ce message qu' il ya un sujet
qu'il faut que les scientifiques que les
journalistes soient mieux formés
puis les scientifiques pareil face et
des questions très très systémique
j'aime bien ça c'est les conditions de
travail des journalistes et conditions
travail des scientifiques et il faut
qu'on trouve un moyen soit de faire avec
soin de revoir de changer ses conditions
vivre en cd production de l'information
j'ai vu sarah ajouté qu' il ya un gros
enjeu derrière c'est pas juste pour
pinailler avec les copines assez on a je
pense que 21e siècle a plein de ton jeu
énorme à venir le défi à relever
soit 161 s'armer autant que possible de
l'information de qualité autant que
possible pour pouvoir adresser les
nombreux enjeux à venir conclut à la
matca merci beaucoup
nikop17 leurs discussions parce que si
on était proche le court je pense que ça
fait 2 e je continue encore bas merci en
tout cas aux auditeurs et je vous dis à
bientôt probablement à bientôt